favorable si c'est vraiment un bon coup
peut-être
comme vous êtes une fille sérieuse
qu'elle a peut-être sur les épaules on
va faire une interview sérieuse ou alors
sérieusement pas sexuel d'accord je suis
pas
interview prise de tête
est-ce que vous êtes favorable aux
relations sexuelles avant le mariage
vous êtes favorable au mariage
oui si les deux personnes sont
consentantes
l'idée de la religion dans l'histoire
d'amour j'ai encore du mal à savoir
pourquoi ça existe mais c'est ça crée le
mariage Ludivine c'est vrai j'ai pas
encore pris conscience de
sacralité et de cet engagement
il va falloir je pense non va falloir
sinon vous allez faire un mariage de
merde c'est vrai c'est vrai bien sûr
bien sûr à la Mairie du 15e
est-ce que vous êtes favorable à la
sexualité hors mariage
favorable si c'est vraiment un bon coup
peut-être
non je sais pas ça dépend des conditions
si le mariage si c'est marié votre mari
vous satisfait pas vraiment bon
imaginons vous trompez
jusqu'ici tout va bien imaginons c'est
une vue de l'esprit et vous êtes prête à
le tromper avec le premier bon coup venu
beaucoup c'est pas toujours le premier
venu faut le trouver
contraception
à l'avortement
l'amour à plusieurs
vous êtes favorable au suicide
oui mais oui oui
faut tomber bien bas quand même
je pense que le
l'autre côté de la mort on a envie
d'aller voir quand même peut-être rien à
voir
une curiosité tout à l'heure
et tu te dis tiens
ouais on est dans la merde ça va mal se
passer ça va finir mais en même temps
peut-être que de l'autre côté il y a un
truc formidable donc on a dit il y a une
dualité à ce moment-là
qui peut être créatif aussi
même quand les gens vont bien
parce que là ça pose plus de problèmes
j'avais dit prise de tête un tant pis
pour vous je sais pas j'ai pas
l'impression que ce soit encore super
bien réglé éthiquement parlant donc je
vais regarder pour l'instant j'ai pas
fait de projets d'enfants
pas plus
en pensez
ça dépend des jours
il y a des jours où
si j'imaginais qu'on tuer quelqu'un de
proche de moi elle sait pas quoi
ouais j'aurais tendance à souhaiter sa
mort ou même essayer de la provoquer
moi-même je pense mais sur la
philosophie tu crois tant qu'on est pas
dans dans immédiatement immergé en
première ligne
sinon a priori je pense pas que la peine
de mort résolve grand chose si ce n'est
de se débarrasser de façon définitive de
quelqu'un qui vous a été hostile ce qui
n'est pas obligatoirement une mauvaise
manière non plus donc ça dépend les
jours lundi je suis pour mardi non
mercredi j'hésite jusqu'à midi jeudi
vendredi je suis contre le dimanche
quand je m'emmerde vraiment je peux le
redevenir
est-ce que vous êtes favorable à la
peine de mort pour ceux qui sont pour la
peine de mort
n'a toujours pas au droit de vote pour
les immigrés
un tout petit pouvoir de pour voter pour
des gens qui règle leur droit c'est
évidemment
pourquoi le vote de quelqu'un qui est là
depuis 6 mois qui n'a aucun intérêt
commun avec toi le problème c'est la
communauté d'intérêt qui donne la droit
à la communauté de vote donc un immigré
et là depuis un an ou deux ans et qui
dans un système auquel il est dans
lequel il est contraintes vivent comme
nous tous ne va pas pourquoi on lui
demanderait pas son avis sur des choses
tout à fait possible en fait tu es
contre le droit de vote pour les
touristes finalement
c'est ça
je veux pas qu'il y ait des je veux pas
que à Roissy tu es les flics la douane
les urnes c'est tout donc le mec reste
un peu est-ce que vous êtes favorable à
la réouverture des maisons closes
elles sont déjà ouvertes
localisation du cabanisme plutôt ouais
[Musique]
mettez un pouce bleu